welcome to CBS this morning we're going
to begin with this Robert Muller it's a
big deal is agreed to answer questions
from Congress for the first time since
his investigation of Russian election
interference began more than two years
ago the chairman of the House Judiciary
and intelligence committees announced
this deal last night
the former special counsel will appear
on July 17th President Trump called the
news presidential harassment mother's
report you may recall found the
president and his campaign did not
collude with Russia but it did not clear
him of obstruction of justice and
Democrats want to know why Muller had
said the report speaks for itself and he
previously resisted calls for him to
testify Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
Nancy Robert Muller made very clear he
did not want to do this so how did it
happen well it took months of
negotiations and in the end a pair of
subpoenas - for smaller off of the fence
and into the witness chair and so now in
a few weeks time he will appear before
two committees taking questions from
Democrats and Republicans in public
about his two-year investigation he was
very reluctant to testify and it was
necessary to issue a subpoena but he has
agreed to comply with it Muller had made
no secret of his reluctance to testify
he said he preferred to let his 400-page
report speak for itself
I would not provide information beyond
that which is already public and any
appearance before Congress in their new
joint letter to Muller House Judiciary
Chairman Jerry Nadler and House
Intelligence Chairman Adam Schiff said
they would work with Muller to address
legitimate concerns about preserving the
integrity of his work Democrats want to
ask him about the 10 ways the report
says the president tried to interfere
with the investigation if we had had
confidence that the president clearly
did not commit a crime we would have
said so they also want to know why
Muller stopped short of recommending mr.
Trump be charged with obstruction of
justice
another topic expected to come up is
Muller's letter to Attorney General
William Barr in which he complained that
Barr did not fully capture the substance
of his report the letters a bit snitty
and I think it was probably
written by one of his staff people in an
exclusive interview last month barstool
Jan Crawford he wouldn't object to
Muller testifying as I said you know
it's up to Bob but I think the line he's
drawing which is that he's going to
stick to what he said in the report is
the proper line for any Department
official CBS News has learned that the
White House will not try to block or
limit Muller's testimony and the
president's attorney hopes Republicans
take the opportunity to question the
credibility of Muller's team some
Republicans have questioned the need to
hear from Muller at all it is case
closed for me so they can do anything
they want to in the house and I think
it'll blow up in their face
the chairs acknowledge that there are
certain sensitive areas that Muller
won't be able to get into in public like
the ongoing criminal cases that his team
referred to other offices at the
Department of Justice so they plan to do
some of the questioning in public and
then move to a more secure area so that
they could ask other questions Tony in
private well about those questions Nancy
as you point out robert muller
previously said the report is my
testimony and he said he wouldn't go
outside the four corners of it so what
are democrats hoping to get out of this
well they see his testimony as vital to
their investigations of obstruction of
justice even if he isn't able to go much
beyond what he has already laid out in
the report and beyond that Democrats
think that having a neutral arbiter like
Muller answer questions in public about
obstruction is going to help them make
their case to the American people that
the president broke the law and
potentially Tony should be impeached all
right Nancy thank you very much